in furnace parking lot
[Music]
and some cold beer
what was it about uptown that made you
guys want to get on board it was a hit
smash
[Music]
welcome to certified country I'm so fish
Lacy and today we are with the boys of
Florida Georgia line and the boys that
they want you to know and know I am NOT
talking about Backstreet Boys although
sit tight because we are gonna come back
to that one first though we got to talk
about Chris Lane and Morgan Wallen both
members of FG ELLs big loud family Chris
open for the guys on their smooth
stadium tour this summer and Morgan
scored an FGL feature on his new single
[Music]
before FGL hit it huge they counted on
support from stars like Jay Cohen Luke
Bryan even labelmate Taylor Swift who
brought them out on her red tour back in
2013 today though Tyler and Bryan are
super passionate about giving a boost to
up-and-coming artists that they know and
love everybody needs help everybody
needs guidance everybody needs a mentor
and I feel like the country music
community whether you're in a solo
artist a group a duo a band whatever
everybody wants to give a helping hand
and a little bit of a device here and
there goes a long way for us it's it's a
it's a really special life that we get
to live no doubt do you feel like you've
made it now it's hard not to think we've
made it when you look at every night and
see 30,000 people singing your songs and
but at the same time we're big dreamers
and we really kind of say the sky's the
limit so let's see where this thing is
gonna go we kind of continue to keep
that motto and just kind of see where it
leads us what are like your three tips
for making it not just in country music
but crossing over as well don't worry
about the word know just just continue
to hear yes in your mind and don't ever
give up and surround yourself with great
people great team and a positive
attitude and just work on your crap and
be the best that you can be
[Music]
when I had the opportunity to take FGL
out with me their first-year Rutland
crews hit I was like I felt like I'd won
the lottery I mean it's an honor that I
can be associated with them they're an
unbelievable AG that brings it every
night
Luke's definitely got that right with us
sometimes polarizing but always
undeniable presence in the country
community FGL has now set their sights
on pop stardom through duets with the
Backstreet Boys bebe Rexha and Hailee
Steinfeld to name only a few because if
there's one thing that these guys really
know it is the value of a strong
collaboration how long have you known
Tyler right I guess it's been about a
year year and a half or so and kind of
just became friends and I had no
expectations or you know no thought of
us even haven't stolen together I kind
of was trying to do my own thing and you
know obviously watching them do their I
don't think so to be able to to get a
collab going it's really awesome and I
feel like we have a good way together
it's an honest song you know everything
that I put out is almost we like to have
a good time we like to fish so I got to
drink a little bit you know
[Music]
let's talk about that music video it
looked like so much fun it was a lot of
fun I think I just got a new boat that
was because testbed yeah it was a pretty
pretty natural day and we just kind of I
didn't even feel like we were really
recording yeah it was a great time
well you competed on the sixth season of
The Voice yeah team uh sure and team
Adam yeah yeah how did that experience
sort of impact you as an artist you know
it did I that was the first thing that I
had really done as an artist you know I
I didn't grow up be that that was not my
dream I wanted to play baseball and then
that kind of got taken away from me my
mom signed me up for that show I've
never even been on the plane or anything
oh my god they send me to California and
I'm out there you know for six to eight
months and I see how different the world
really is out there and how different it
is from what I've known it kind of
helped me to figure out how much I love
where I'm wrong now how proud I am of it
and how much I really love that way of
life meanwhile back here in Los Angeles
the worlds of pop and country were
colliding with Tori Kelly and Chris Lane
only I was invited to the set of their
new music video for take back homegirl
which will be available in full on
November 6th here's her sneak peek
[Music]
I've been a big fan of Tori's for quite
some time and I had this song that I was
looking for a duet with and they asked
me who's your a dream collaboration
partner and she was the first person I
said random text from my manager sending
me the song he was like do you like it
and I was like actually I'm obsessive it
now this is gonna be the first offering
off of your next album yeah yes so this
is gonna be the first thing off my
second record I've been working on a
whole bunch of songs but I really love
this song I believe in this song and I'm
so happy to have somebody that I love in
it
[Music]
you're also on the road out on the road
right now on the smooth tour with
Florida Georgia line and Nellie which
I've been having the time of my life
with those guys but yeah as soon as that
tour ends at the end of October I'm
gonna be starting my first ever
headlining tour thank you
I need chance you're bringing this girl
out with you we got to see the song live
you guys you know what at some point I
hope if I know she's got a busy schedule
with her touring and in the studio and
all that kind of stuff but you know what
if it lines up with schedules and
whatnot I will have her out any day of
the week to do that now I you know I'm
not gonna let you off the hook without
asking a little romance question what's
your status single taken yeah so I'm
currently single okay I've been for a
while again sure sure yeah sign me up
for The Bachelor right
[Applause]
by yutori I'm gonna put you on the spot
here a special guy in your life can you
tell us anything about him no just a few
days after that interview Tori actually
announced that she's engaged so
congratulations are in order for her now
before we go I do want to bring things
back around to this backstreet bromance
now I don't want to start any crazy
rumors or anything but let's just say I
asked BS be straight-up about working
with FGL again take a look at what they
said any chance we can expect another
duet with you I think this this
partnership has stuck around a lot
longer than maybe we expected possibly
no guys you know we have an album that
we're working on right now so we may ask
those guys to return the favor you know
what I'm saying tell me about the album
that you guys are working out - we came
here to record a song here in Nashville
Florida Georgia line involved okay I'm
just saying that sounds really suspect
to me I'm just gonna leave it at that
thank you so much for watching and if
this is your first time seeing our show
please like and subscribe to
Entertainment Tonight on YouTube
I am bringing you exclusive interviews
every Friday with stars like Blake
Shelton Kelsea Ballerini Thomas Rhett
and so many more stay tuned and I will
see you again next Friday right here on
YouTube